Buenas tardes pues además de todo esto
que estas precisiones que hizo Emmanuel
maco antes de esta gira por África
Central es importante ver que una vez
más toca el tema de querer de verdad
pasar la página lo había anunciado en su
discurso en agua eso fue en 2017 y hoy
una vez más vuelve a decir que a partir
de ahora comienza una nueva era en las
relaciones entre Francia y el continente
africano unas relaciones de mucho más
equilibrio de mucho más respeto también
y sobre todo con Francia tratando de dar
una visión bastante humilde aceptando
los errores que se que se pudieron
cometer y también habló acerca de de
algo que ha sido importante también para
algunas naciones africanas y es la
restitución de bienes culturales Manuel
macan dijo que en las próximas semanas
habría la presentación de un nuevo
proyecto de ley para nuevas
restituciones restituciones que ya se
hicieron hace algunos años a Costa de
Marfil pero también más recientemente se
fue hace un par de años y sobre todo
pues estas piezas que muchas veces se
encuentran en los museos
pues necesitan cada una de una ley
precisa por cada una de de de digamos de
estas restituciones que además debe ser
aprobado por el parlamento Así que esto
también da paso a un a un nuevo digamos
a un nuevo comienzo o digamos una nueva
etapa en las relaciones entre entre
Francia y África sobre todo también pues
esto da pie a digamos a dar un sentido y
a mostrar a qué va Emmanuel de nuevo al
continente africano esta Será su visita
número 18 a ese continente y justamente
cuando todo ese sentimiento antifrancés
ha venido creciendo en el en en varios
países africanos especialmente en Mali
especialmente en burkina faso dos de los
países de los que los militares
franceses tuvieron que salir unos en
agosto y más recientemente ya cuando Se
confirmó se oficializó eso hace una
semana